[Musique]
J'ai grandi en regardant ces films de monstres
quand j'étais petit. Je me souviens avoir été
complètement terrifié. Il y a quelque
chose dans ces premiers films d'horreur qu'Alex
veut leur rendre dignement honneur. Nous devons
au public un film de monstres, donc la clé
pour nous était de  racontez une histoire qui semblait
réelle notre image se déroule à l'
époque moderne ce qui est intéressant dans la façon dont
ces histoires sont racontées, c'est que vous vous identifiez
à ces personnages classiques ils
nous terrifient et pourtant vous ressentez de la sympathie pour
eux bienvenue dans le bouddhisme ces décors sont
magnifiques ils sont beaux  ils
hantent le monde se sentiront énormes nous avons
tourné une énorme séquence d'action ici au
cœur de l'Afrique
nous allons en apesanteur à l'intérieur d'un vrai
avion c'est tellement bon que vous pouvez le faire Annabelle
Wallis est géniale elle ne
nous a même jamais touchés signalez-le elle est  faire ça le casting
ils sont tellement talentueux
vous avez Russell Crowe Jake Johnson
ces gars qui sont amusants à regarder avec
Russell je me connais depuis plus de 20
ans nous avons parlé de travailler
ensemble  là maintenant nous allons faire cette
amie très cool
sofia boutella apporte une véritable humanité à
la momie mais même quand elle fait
des choses horribles, le public peut
s'attendre à être atrocement
terrifié tom a dit que c'est plus grand que
tout ce que j'ai jamais fait avant c'est  comme
être sur un tour de montagnes russes c'est
ce que ce film va livrer ça
va vous garder juste au bord de
votre siège vous ne voudrez pas
quitter l'écran des yeux c'est très amusant
[Musique]
[  Musique]
Oh
[Musique]
Bienvenue dans un nouveau monde de dieux et de
monstres, il est réel
[Musique]
Veuillez rencontrer la princesse Je suis Annette,
elle prétendra
mais elle a été refusée
[Musique]
vous